[Musique]
je suis aurélien guillemets chargé de
développement économique au sein de la
chambre de métiers d'artisanat de
l'essonne et je suis votre référent
numérique vos démarches administratives
et commerciales vont changer au 1er
janvier 2020 avec l'utilisation de la
plateforme cosco cette plateforme
numérique permet de saisir en direct vos
factures pas besoin d'un autre logiciel
cette pleine forme elle permet également
de suivre vos factures c'est à dire que
vous pouvez voir les différentes étapes
que va traverser ce document
administratif
est ce qu'il a été reçu et ce qu'il est
en cours de traitement ou ce que ça a
été pays si vous confier la mission de
la réalisation de certaines factures ou
de certains de vie à vos collaborateurs
chorus pro permis de créer un espace par
utilisateur mais vous restez le seul
décisionnaire de l'envoi de ses
documents administratifs auprès des
établissements publics
cette plateforme numérique permet
également de programmer l'envoi de
factures ou de vie ce qui permet de
mieux vous organiser en interne avec
l'utilisation de la plateforme corrige
pro nous sommes dans une relation
gagnant gagnant plus de sécurité plus de
rapidité et moins de papier ce n'est
besoin de plus de renseignements ou
d'infos pratiques
venez faire le point sur votre
entreprise avec votre conseiller c'est
maïs là
[Musique]